but first our very own genie mike
jenkins
[Applause]
new mom jeannie mai is back on the rail
i get excited about the show the tv
personality returns to the studio
following the birth of daughter monaco
hey it's so nice to be back and making
so much money
i'm being serious no i'm seriously
saying i miss you guys so much it's so
good to be
here three months after giving birth
jeannie shares an update on life as a
mom i want to know okay so it's been
three months into motherhood how are you
feeling how are you dealing i feel alive
you look great though thank you as
jeannie tells it nothing could have
prepared her for the experience
everything a mom has ever said about
being a mom all the cliche things you
don't know until it's your own you've
never loved anything like this before
like all those things have come true and
i feel it and i understand amazing it's
beautiful and how about this her first
episode bag is capped off with a
wardrobe malfunction but jeannie handles
it like the pro she is even laughing
while showing off her ripped dress
jeannie we are so happy you're back
[Applause]
jeannie also took to the real's
instagram story proving she's clearly
got a balance on work and family life
stay back
and i'm uncle i already called the baby
through my mom like six times already my
uterus hurts i miss her like crazy but
i'm so happy to be back i love you fam
ah thank you for having me and before
her official tv homecoming
jeannie stopped by the talk show in
january for a heartwarming reveal
okay so
i am very excited to share that monaco
mai jenkins
is
a girl
[Applause]
there's just so many reasons why
raising a little girl is such an honor
to me and i would have been happy with
anything but to have monaco i i can't
tell you i feel chosen i'm it's
emotional genie and gz real name jay
jenkins tied the knot in 2021 a year
after getting engaged this is her first
child in the rapper's fourth soon after
saying i do
genie gushed to et about married life
married life feels 1 000 different than
when we were dating
in the greatest way it's i loved our
dating life because we really spent such
concentrated quality time getting to
know each other and making sure that we
were right for each other but now being
married
it's even more handheld with such
delicacy and such thoughtfulness because
we're in our 40s and we both
had we both were we both grew up in
households that weren't healthy
marriages
and we also have never seen what that
looks like but in our intuition we all
know what we want we want to feel
trusted we want to feel love we want to
feel safe we want to feel cuddles we
want to feel you know the romance and so
the fact that i'm doing that with a
partner that is like-minded with me is
the best part of my life welcome back
genie
[Music]
you